so quadrilateral ABCD they're telling us
it is a rhombus and what we need to do
we need to prove that the area of this
rhombus is equal to 1/2 times AC times
BD so we're essentially proving that the
area of a rhombus is 1/2 times the
product of the lengths of its diagonals
so let's see what we can do over here so
there's a bunch of things we know about
rhombi and all rhombi our parallelogram
so we there's tons of things that we
know about parallelograms first of all
if it's a rhombus we know that all of
the sides are congruent so that side
length is equal to that side length is
equal to that side length is equal to
that side length because it's a
parallelogram we know that diagonals
bisect each other so we know that this
length let me call this point over here
B let's call this e we know that b e is
going to be equal to e d so that's b e
we know that's going to be equal to e d
and we know that a e we know that AE is
equal to EC
we also know because this is a rhombus
and we proved this in the last video
that the diagonals not only do they
bisect each other but they are also
perpendicular so we know that this is a
right angle this is a right angle that
is a right angle and then this is a
right angle so the easiest way to think
about it is if we can show that this
triangle ADC is congruent to triangle
ABC and if we can figure out the area of
one of them we can just double it so the
first part is pretty straight forward so
we can see the triangle ADC we know that
triangle a DC is going to be congruent
to triangle ABC to triangle a b c and we
know that by side-side-side congruence
this side is congruent to that side this
side is congruent to that side and they
both share a C right over here so this
is by side-side-side and so we can say
that the area so because of that because
of that we know that the area of ABCD
the area of ABCD is just going to be
equal to 2 times 2 times the area of we
could pick either one of these we could
say 2 times the area of
ABC 2 times the area of ABC because the
area of ABCD actually let me write it
this way the area of ABCD is equal to
the area of a DC plus the area of ABC
but since they're congruent these two
are going to be the same thing so it's
just going to be two times the area of a
b c now what is the area of a b c well
area of a triangle is just 1/2 base
times height so area of a b c is just
equal to 1/2 times the base of that
triangle times its height which is equal
to 1/2 what is the length of the base
well the length of the base is AC so
it's 1/2 I'll color code it the base is
AC and then what is the height what is
the height here well we know that this
this this diagonal right over here
there's a perpendicular bisector so the
height the height is just the distance
from be e so it's AC times ve b e that
is the height this is an altitude this
is it intersects this base at a
90-degree angle or we could say B E is
the same thing as 1/2 times BD so this
is let me write this is equal to so it's
equal to 1/2 times AC AC that's our base
and then our height is B E which we're
saying is the same thing as 1/2 times BD
which is 1/2 times BD so that's it
that's the area of just ABC that's just
the area of this broader triangle right
up there or that larger triangle right
up there that half of the rhombus but we
just said that the area of the whole
thing is 2 times that so the area so if
we go back if we use both this
information and this information right
over here we have the area of ABCD is
going to be equal to 2 times the area of
ABC well the area of ABC is this thing
right over here it is so 2 times the
area of ABC or
baby see is that right over there so 1/2
times 1/2 is 1/4 times a C times B D and
then you see where this is going
2 times 1/4 is 1/2 times AC times BD
fairly straightforward which is a neat
result and what actually I haven't done
this in a video yet I'll do in the next
video there are other ways of finding
the areas of parallelograms generally
it's essentially base times height but
for a rhombus we could do that because
it is a parallelogram but we also have
this other neat little result that we
proved in this video that if we know the
lengths of the diagonals the area of the
rhombus is 1/2 times the lengths the
products of the lengths of the diagonals
which is kind of a neat result